many school districts around the country
they are improving or they're reviewing
building security after tuesday's
massacre there's also more talk about
the so-called hardening of schools and
in many places the federal government is
paying the bill for that scott mcfarlane
is on capitol hill with the numbers add
up to tens of millions of dollars scott
good morning to you
hey gail good morning to you congress is
paralyzed by gridlock in changing gun
laws but some schools aren't just
standing by idly they want money to
tighten up their security and a review
of public records by cbs news shows
washington has been doling out quite a
bit of it
many students were greeted with extra
security on wednesday in the wake of the
shootings in uvalde
school districts from texas to missouri
to arizona to virginia tell cbs news
they're reviewing policies or staffing
or ordering new training to keep
students safe amid the congressional
stalemate over new gun laws the
superintendent in millville new jersey
isn't waiting he's been upgrading
security for months the security
vestibules we have cameras we have a
we have a response of panic alarms to
the two first responders today a series
of senators is recommending hardening of
schools but a review of justice
department records obtained by cbs news
show washington has already spent more
than 150 million dollars since 2018
doing so through school violence
prevention grants and for a wide range
of items the records show schools in
roselle new jersey sought grants for new
digital security radios in logan county
west virginia the justice department
provided 194 thousand dollars to help
pay for cameras for door locks and
training for in-school police because
you're concerned about
mitigating the risk of a school shooting
is that part of the motivation the
primary
number one responsibility of of all
school personnel
is to make certain that every student
that attends
our schools are returned safely to their
parents
that evening we found the money
distributed by the u.s justice
department in grants is more than
doubled since 2018. even new jersey
democrat cory booker who's championed
school safety grants in the past says
hardening of schools is not a solution
to gun violence i mean what kind of
testimony is it
that we declare that we can't protect
our schools from from people with guns
so we're going to build bunkers and
castles for our children
and does that solve this problem no
the u.s attorney general has just asked
congress for 53 million dollars next
year for these school security grants
and we went through them and found a
number of schools including that logan
county west virginia district use some
of the money for mental health training
for staff
michelle
scott thank you